but I had no idea everyone make fun of
me now I had no idea who your parents
were right until last night until last
night I was like why did I keep talking
about the Mamas and the Papas in the
beach fathers like what does this have
to do and I was like what no like I just
want you to know like I guess a couple
on your own merit I was married had
nothing do you hear it that's coming and
I think that that's kind of something
cuz like to grow up and I imagine that
was very hard I'm gauging and navigating
that with my kids I'm sure you have to
as well but being in the public eye
having parents so famous
and trying to navigate that and like
what is normal and how do I
it was no no we also have a great mom
Marilyn who's in the audience but she
was really she was really great at
keeping it you know steady and and being
real about things you know not
everything is normal or what is normal
and you know building our self-esteem
and as people and and showing us love
and that and now we instill that in our
kids yeah it's important it's a weird
thing to navigate but like I know so
since finding that out and I kind of
read anything about like one of you was
put to bed by Sir Elton John and I was
like yeah what what is your life oh yeah
your house by or something I don't get
it why don't I know he reminded me when
I was just on the talk with him a couple
years ago that don't you remember I put
you to sleep and I'm like what I know
but I'm telling everyone he literally
can't I mean he just well he wanted to
buy dad's piano that he wrote that dad
wrote Good Vibrations on that was always
you know solid piano a lot a lot of
memories there and he wanted this piano
he came over and he was probably begging
for it my mom said no but he I guess I
came downstairs when they were chatting
and doing that thing and he said it's
time to go back to bed and put me at my
and that was a Elton John Freeman asleep
okay the man my heart it turns out of
this story actually isn't that it's the
fact that your mom was like no you can't
have our piano Elton John I know what
that piano is mine now so I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this